Sam bman freed is facing 115 years in
prison for fraud and I flew to New York
City to watch it all happen live we'll
be breaking it all down here in the $40
million Bahama Penthouse what happened
with FTX who the big players are and
everything about this trial start to
finish but first let me be honest this
is not a quick story I'm going to
simplify but try not to oversimplify
which is difficult given that there are
a thousand pages of transcripts and
government evidence so to tackle this
here's what I'm going to do I'm going to
give you the prosecution and defense's
arguments in order as the jury would
hear them two competing Visions for what
happened with FTX then we'll give you
the witness testimony that ultimately
will decide the fate of one of the
largest frauds we've ever seen and you
at home can decide what you believe is
Sam innocent or guilty let's get
started all right this is pretty boring
they just selected the
jury all right this is where things get
more interesting uh we got got opening
statements today the prosecution's
arguments is basically that s bman freed
created an elaborate fraud using two
companies FTX where customers could go
deposit their money and Alam research
which then stole that money from FTX now
on the surface Alam was a trading firm
and a market maker both FTX and Alam
were controlled by Sam but it kind of
looked like they were separate entities
like they're both successful but
separate now that wasn't true the
companies weren't separate and Alam
research got special privileges which
they used to steal the customer money by
the time anyone found out it was already
too late according to the prosecutions
lawyers a year ago the truth started to
come out customers tried to get their
money back but that money the customer's
money was gone the defendant had taken
it now on the other side you have the
defense who says yeah FTX collapsed but
Sam didn't intend to defraud anyone
quote Sam believed that loans that FTX
made to Alama were permitted and backed
by reasonable security but if that's
true why did things fail well think of
FTX like a plane Sam and his colleagues
were building the plane as they were
flying it I mean it's so easy to blame
people in hindsight but is it that
simple quote to listen to the
government's openings there were no
employees it was Sam doing everything by
himself that wasn't true no one person
no CEO certainly not Sam could be
everywhere and as a result some things
got overlooked and the defense is Right
8 billion things did indeed go
overlooked but their point is this if
blame is to go anywhere look at it was
actually the CEO of alam research at the
time it wasn't Sam it was his
ex-girlfriend Caroline Ellison and
speaking of Caroline she's going to be
testifying later against Sam in this
trial so the defense is eager to
discredit her and the other FTX
Executives who are also testifying
against Sam the defense says that all
these people entered cooperation
agreements which incentivizes them to
testify against against Sam and make him
sound as bad as possible to get their
sentence lessened or as they would put
it quote are they spinning things that
Sam said that were good faith business
decisions and now claiming they were
Sinister and they knew it all along
that's the story of the prosecution and
the defense elaborate fraud or
well-meaning failure uh before you make
up your mind though know that neither of
these two have really presented much
evidence so to believe either of their
stories that's really what we're waiting
for and of course that's going to come
through Witnesses speaking of witnesses
this is where things get pretty lopsided
to be honest the prosecution has all the
witnesses they have pages of witnesses
while the defense basically has none
except for Sam himself who probably
shouldn't take the stand so everyone
you'll be hearing from today is
testifying against Sam and with that in
mind let's kick off with our first
witness it's a customer of FTX Mark
Anthony juliard now the first thing we
find out is that Mark had $100,000 on
FTX right before everything collapsed
and he saw Sam bankman free tweet this
FTX is fine assets are fine FTX has
enough to cover all client Holdings we
don't invest client assets even in
treasuries and Mark seeing this and
trusting Sam didn't withdraw his money
in early November only to realize later
he couldn't withdraw it and FTX declared
bankruptcy the point is Mark was hurt
because s b mfried lied about FTX being
fine or so the prosecution says now the
defensive turn came to cross-examine him
and they said hey you knew crypto was
new and also a risky asset didn't you
yes you could make a lot you could also
lose a lot yes the defense asked Mark if
he had read the terms of service Mark
said he did not which I get what they're
doing here just kind of making him seem
Reckless but I found it personally
besides the point which is that SPF lied
about the health of his company I found
it unconvincing ing but you guys know
I'm a little biased here now up next the
prosecution calls their next witness
Adam yida who is a long-term friend of s
b m freed not only that Adam worked at
FTX and he was asked to explain why he
abruptly quit one day he says quote I
learned that Alam research had used
customer deposits to pay back its loans
to creditors which might sound bad uh
but it's about to get a lot
[Music]
worse all right Adam yida is still up
and he explains that early on FTX had
trouble opening its own bank account so
to get customer money in quote the
deposits were received in a different
bank account labeled the north Dimension
bank account who controlled it Alam
according to Adam Adam claims that if he
knew Alam was spending the money it
would have raised concerns for him why
well then the money wouldn't be there
for the customer if the customer wanted
it and here's where we learned about an
account called the Fiat at FTX .c
account this was the internal account
where FTX tracked how much Alam owed
them for their customer deposits why is
this important well Adam found out by
looking at it one day that Alam owed FTX
$8 billion in 2022 which concerned him
quote I had a conversation with Sam what
was your reaction to this $8 billion
liability that led to your conversation
with Sam it concerned me why did it
concern you it seemed like a lot of
money for Alam to be owing FTX and I
wanted to be certain that Alam could
repay that debt spoiler alert it
couldn't now Sam allegedly responded at
the time we were bulletproof last year
being 2021 but we're not bulletproof
this year in cross-examination the
defense tried to ask Adam about Sam's
car which if that feels unrelated to
this point it is they say quote do you
know what car he did Drive no did you
recall seeing a Toyota Corolla in terms
of clothes he didn't buy fancy clothes
right I didn't see him wear fancy
clothes to be honest I felt this was a
big Miss for the defense to tackle the
actual issue the prosecution is claiming
Sam knew how bad things were and chose
to lie about it uh so that kind of went
unanswered and speaking of the
prosecution Matt hang is up next Now
Matt works for Paradigm as we would
learn which invested almost $300 million
in FTX but before they did that they
were worried about Alam getting special
treatment on FTX to which Matt emailed
them worrying about value leakage
through Alam Matt claims quote I recall
that we were told there was no
preferential treatment for Alam this we
would soon find out was a lie when the
next witness Gary Wang took the stand
after another disappointing
cross-examination by the defense now
who's Gary Wang he's really important
he's the co-founder of both FTX and Alam
research he's super important because he
was present for all the big moments and
he claims basically the opposite of Sam
Sam said there was no preferential
treatment of alam Gary says we gave
special privileges to Alam research on
FTX which allowed it to withdraw
unlimited amounts of funds from the
platform and we lied about this to the
public now remember the jury just heard
from our last witness that there was no
special privileges and then the
co-founder like yeah we did and we lied
we lied about it uh this entire section
was pretty horrible for the defense
Gary's asked question did you commit
Financial crimes while working at FTX
yes did you commit these Crimes by
yourself or with other people with other
people who are the main other people uh
Sam MRE thead Singh and Caroline Ellison
now all those other people took
cooperation agreements against Sam it's
like they're all just it's like all the
people who are at this company are all
pointing their finger at this one guy
but we're not even done yet
[Music]
today the prosecution shows Gary Wang's
code which he wrote for FTX which gave
Alam research special privileges in it
there's this special function they
created called allow negative which was
switched on for Alam research and
basically no one else in the code they
show that if an account had that they
were allowed to have negative balances
without anything happening now this
meant two things one if Alam research
made a bad trade nothing happened and
two it allowed Alam to basically have
infinite withdrawals from FTX again from
the transcript question so did this
special Advantage allow Alam to make
unlimited withdrawals off the FTX
exchange yes if alam's account balance
was zero or negative and it used the
special advantage to withdraw Bitcoin
whose Bitcoin would it be withdrawing
answer from customers it would be
withdrawing customers Bitcoin now that
says it all and the point of this
testimony is not just a highlight that
Alam could and did steal money from
customers it was also showing that Sam
was kind of willing to lie about that
fact because the prosecution then shows
a tweet from 2019 when Sam is asked once
again about conflicts of interest
running FTX and a trading firm Alam
which runs their trades on FTX Sam's
response was that alam's account is just
like everyone else and the beating
didn't stop there the prosecution uh
then hammered Sam on this like insurance
fund thing they had if you don't know
what that is basically in the event that
FTX took losses they claimed that there
was this Insurance Fund which they
bragged in a tweet was worth over a100
million Gary Wang then explained that
the purpose of this fund was this quote
if an account does not get liquidated in
time that other customers of FTX won't
be affected makes sense an $100 million
Insurance Fund does sound comforting if
it were true turn turns out FTX lied
question was the number on this tweet
accurate answer no why not for one
there's no ftt in the Insurance Fund and
two the number does not match what do
you mean it does not match the number in
the databases was a different number
question is it a real number answer no
so it's a fake number yes was the real
number higher or lower than the fake
number lower so they just fake the D to
look better but if you're wondering how
the prosecution pulls up the code and
they ask Gary hey it looks like it takes
the daily volume multiplies it by a
random number and divides by a billion
answer yes does that number have
anything to do with the actual number of
the inurance fund no this was the exact
moment guys I knew I had to go visit
this trial in person I knew things were
bad with FTX I didn't know they were
make things up with random numbers
levels of bad for our Insurance Fund so
um based on this I took the next flight
out to New York City from the Bahamas
and uh I can't believe what I saw now
I'm going to warn you guys right now
they they didn't allow us to film in
here so all I got was really just like a
little bit of b-roll but in terms of
experiencing it I Really Got A Feeling
for what it was like in the actual
courtroom seeing Caroline seeing Sam
seeing Gary which brings us
to so Gary Wang is still on the stand uh
in cross-examination at this point I'm
in the courtroom with my little notebook
and I followed the trial around enough
to know that the the defense really
needs to land some Jabs here right
they've been taking a beating so far so
you know I I I take my seat uh and I get
ready for fireworks right this is their
moment and to their credit the defense
brings up something called nav net asset
value this is their Silver Bullet
question are you familiar with the term
net asset value yes that's sometimes
called nav yes yes it just means that
your assets minus your liabilities right
roughly speaking yes if you have a
positive nav you have more assets than
you have liabilities right yes the
defense then goes on to get Gary to
admit that technically in 2022 he
calculated that alam's net asset value
was positive Gary says yes and they push
again isn't it true that alam's net
asset value remained positive all the
way up to November of 2022 which is when
things collapsed answer it depends a lot
on how much value you ass assigned to
alam's Investments which is kind of true
but is it's also like a lot of a Dodge
even from my very biased perspective you
know I was writing in here I was just
like I don't know the actual answer from
Gary should have been here yes that's
true alam's balance sheets showed a
positive net asset value as late as
November but the Nuance of why is what
really matters here to understand it
we're going to have to explain liquid
vers illiquid assets so to do that I've
flown out everyone's favorite bartender
Maxwell to talk about it uh you
know what what are you doing where's the
bar what bar we're doing the thing right
Margo robot in a bubble bath Mark Margo
robot in what are you talking about you
know the big short famous scene great
movie I know what the big short is we're
not doing the big short I think he's
still taking the Michael Lewis thing
pretty seriously I can't watch this just
explain the thing I I boss all right so
basically Sam bankman freed had found a
way to borrow billions from his
customers and billions from crypto
lenders but didn't have the money to pay
everyone back so he decides to Bluff by
loading alam's balance sheet with the
liquid assets the catch was these looked
valuable on paper but were actually
unsellable and and super risky Venture
Capital Sam's crypto coins inner party
loans when you hear them talk about
these liquid assets think
sh meanwhile what Sam owed was all
liquid things with immediate value and
that's how FTX could go bankrupt even
when their net asset value was
positive their assets were and the debts
were legit it's that simple got it good
now all right I hope that helped I
certainly will never forget what I just
saw but now Caroline Ellison is going to
take the stand and talk a great deal
about these a liquid assets Caroline
Ellison of course being the girlfriend
of Sam ex-girlfriend but more
importantly she was the CEO of alam
research when it and FTX collapsed
immediately she admits she is guilty of
fraud money laundering and then she says
that she committed these crimes with Sam
bankman freed the reason she frauded
people is she quote incorrectly stated
the amount of our assets and our
liabilities and made alam's balance
sheets look less risky than it really
was and this is where liquid versus
illiquid assets is going to start to
matter because Caroline was in charge of
creating and sending these balance
sheets to lenders to get more loans and
Sam asks her to start putting their own
cryptocoins they had as part of their
balance sheets things like ftt now
Caroline says she did not initially do
it because it was quote somewhat
misleading because you couldn't actually
sell these coins for what they were
worth on paper and this didn't just
apply to FTX his own coin ftt it applied
to a whole host of coins they called Sam
coins Sam coins of course being a
nickname for coins that Sam played a
large role in or created himself things
like serum Maps oxy salana and the
prosecution asks and where Sam coins
ultimately put on alam's balance sheet
she said yeah even though I guess
initially they didn't so they have all
these coins that they can't really sell
but that look good on paper right that's
really important the rough value of Sam
coins on paper was in the ballpark of $1
billion okay now while she's preparing
these misleading balance sheets Caroline
also claims she learned that Alam
research had loaned billions of dollars
to Sam Gary NAD and other entities
through FTX according to internal
spreadsheets around $5 billion was
loaned out why a lot of it was being
used on investments she said a lot of
early stage startup companies and of
course political donations if you're
from America take a big drink this one
hurts because Sam said that spending
money on politics was very effective
that you could get very high returns in
terms of influence by spending
relatively small small amounts of money
I just want to pause on that moment and
just say it's such a sad indictment of
our government I mean if you're going to
get bought out as a politician can you
at least charge a lot of money you
couldn't buy my influence for less than
$10 million I mean have some
self-respect guys that's all I'm going
to say okay we we need a better standard
but anyways moving on Caroline then
explains that these loans to Executives
were a liquid meaning you couldn't
really sell your stake if you needed to
repay the loans because either iCal
donations or Venture Capital you're just
not going to really get your money back
uh over time Caroline says that she
didn't feel good about including these
loans on alam's balance sheet because
quote that might raise concerns for
alam's lenders and quote they made Alam
significantly riskier Caroline was then
asked about Sam bankman Freed's approach
to risk-taking quote he described
himself as risk neutral meaning that
most people are risk averse but he said
that he was totally comfortable taking a
risk as long as he thought it was a
positive EV EV meaning expected value
Caroline was asked if Sam gave an
example of this and he did he would be
happy to flip a coin and if it came up
tals the world was destroyed as long as
if it came up heads the world would be
more than like twice as good okay the
prosecution I think did not stay on this
point enough this is insane of course
it's not risk neutral it's degenerate
Gambler Behavior this sounds like my
uncle betting it all on dble zero in
Vegas telling me he has a system I mean
there's nothing risk nutral about being
willing to bet the world's destruction
on a coin toss in fact it was so bad the
prosecution then asked for a break and
when they came back the government then
shows this exhibit which is an internal
note the part in Gray was written by Sam
and it's just basically a potential bad
scenario for FTX and Alam why was Sam
think about this well he claimed that he
thought there was a 10% risk chance that
this happened and he wanted Caroline to
look at it some of these worst case
scenario events were like their venture
capital is basically worthless serum
salana FDT all go down 75% you get the
idea and the reason for this at the time
was not purely theoretical CM said he
was thinking of making $3 billion more
in Venture Investments and wanted to
know how that would affect alam's
finances uh Caroline came back and
basically told him it will affect them
badly quote making 3 billion more
Venture Investments would put Alam in a
significantly riskier position and make
it much less likely or almost impossible
that we would be able to pay off our
loans um that's of course bad and this
is an extremely important moment because
it's like someone clearly warning Sam
that he should stop uh so he does that
right no he then tweeted this on January
14th we're launching a $2 billion
Venture fund this is right after he's
told you do this you may collapse your
own company because it's too risky
anyway that's the end of day
five day six October 11th Caroline
Ellison gets back on the stand the jury
is told about May of 2022 we're walking
through the events the crypto Market has
just crashed because of Tera Luna and
crypto lenders are scared Celsius is
collapsing we covered that other lenders
don't want to be overextended and a lot
of them decide to call back their loans
the head of lending and is for example a
large lender to FTX and Alam recalls
$400 million of their loans now this is
bad for Alam cuz they don't have money
and they borrowed billions from their
customers billions from lenders the only
way they're going to pay back one of
those people is to borrow more from the
other so in this case they're going to
take more from customers Caroline then
testifies this quote we didn't have the
liquid assets to pay all the money back
and we would be taking money from FTX
question and whose funds would that be
that would would be coming from customer
funds nevertheless they pay back those
loans anyways 5 days later head of
lending a Genesis texts them again he's
worried might call in more loans he asks
them for a quote more updated view of
equity and balance sheet this is really
important because Caroline says you know
okay yeah I'll put it together but
behind the scenes she's really concerned
because she puts together a regular
balance sheet but when she shows it to
Sam she says quote think it looks bad I
don't think we can send this to Genesis
do you agree and he said yeah that
sounds right now we're going to go
through some of these balance sheets I
know it's going to be complicated at
first but there's only a few numbers you
need to know about here's what the
original one looked like what matters
here is that their liabilities are
massive numbers here are in millions so
14 billion is the total they owed and 9
billion of it are FTX exchange borrows
meaning taken from FTX customers now
their assets are 21 billion which is
technically more but mostly consists of
Sam coins some of which are literally
locked up and then also they have all
these related party loans which they're
counting as assets $4.5 billion we've
talked about that they can't get that
money back so that is why both Sam and
Caroline knew this balance sheet looked
terrible they know they don't have the
actual cash or crypto to cover their
debts according to Caroline Sam then
suggested that I should prepare some
alternative ways of presenting the
information and send them to him
Caroline then creates seven alternate
balance sheets and sends them all to Sam
because quote I didn't really want to be
dishonest but I also didn't want them to
know the truth them meaning Genesis and
of the seven alternate balance sheets
this is the one Sam picked in a side by
side you can notice a few things firstly
the related party loans is gone so is
the word exchange borrows Caroline
claims quote I deleted the related party
loans and I also subtracted the same
amount of money from FTX borrows so that
our nav would remain the same but our
total assets and total liabilities would
would both get lower which to be clear
is accounting fraud but the reason they
did this is what's actually important
which is quote the intended effect this
is Caroline was to make Alam look less
risky than it was and to hide the fact
that we were borrowing around $1 billion
from FTX customers and so what was the
result of all that lying well she sends
it off to Genesis and it backfires
because they keep recalling in loans all
that effort and they're still asked to
repay $500 million in $250 million Clips
to be clear this is the worst case
scenario Sam had dreamed of coming true
by September ftxs borrows will have gone
up to 13.7 billion if you remember just
a bit ago 3 months ago it was 9.9
billion so things are spiraling out of
control and by November things hit a
Breaking Point when that fake balance
sheet which they sent Genesis got leaked
to coindesk a publication and people
started to read it and realized that FTX
just didn't have the money and they
started withdrawing from FTX it's worth
commenting here on the irony that this
fake balance sheet which was supposed to
conceal how bad things were was
ultimately their downfall because even
with all the changes they made it still
looked so bad to scare customers you
know but ultimately the result was
people just started withdrawing all
their money and they couldn't you know
fulfill that and they collapsed I know a
lot of people will point point to CZ
tweeting about FTX as like the Catalyst
for FTX collapsing but actually that was
just extra fuel to the fire the truth
was FTX and Alam just didn't have the
money they hadn't had the money for a
long period of time and that information
got leaked through this like balance
sheet but ultimately that wasn't the
most impactful moment of Caroline's
testimony cuz all these numbers you know
it's hard to know how much the jury is
really resonating with it but what I
know they resonated with is what
happened right after which is when the
government pulled up a grainy text
between Sam and Caroline she's saying
that she's in the best mood I've been in
all year Sam replies why because she
exciting quote I think I just had an
increasing dread of this day it was
waiting on me for a long time and now
that it's actually happening it just
feels great to get it over with one way
or another now what happened next will
not be shown in court records because
transcripts don't show emotions but I
wrote it down cuz I was there in the
courtroom at the time Caroline starts
balling at this point she starts
expressing remorse admitting to lying
crying over her guilt and Dread and look
I'm not going to read you her whole
statement there but I was watching the
jury and I know for a fact they were
moved by this you know they might not
have understood all the numbers they
might not have understood the
embezzlement but they understand when a
CEO starts crying about how guilty they
were about what they were doing what
they knew they were doing the whole time
and I think that was a really powerful
moment and that's basically the end of
the
day the next day Caroline Ellison is up
for cross examination this is really the
defense's chance to kind of land some
shots and of course it doesn't happen
they tried to focus in on the fact that
Caroline is just trying to get a
cooperation agreement like with the
government the implication being that
the only reason she admitted that you
know she defrauded people the only
reason she's crying is because she wants
to get a deal um but the problem with
this was that then in redirect this gets
used against the defense when the
prosecution uses that to release a tape
showing Ellison admitting all of this
prior in an all hands meeting starting
last year um alanita was kind of
borrowing a bunch of money via open term
loans and use that to make various
illiquid Investments um so like a bunch
of sdx and sdx US Equity a bunch of like
other Ventures Investments Etc most of
Al loans got called in order to like
meet those lowary calls um we ended up
like Bing bunch of funds on FDX which
led to FDX having a shortfall in user
funds just in general this looked bad
and and I I just want to say I'm not
trying to make the defense look bad I
understand that I have a bias but if
you're thinking to yourself wow this
video Paints the defense as being bad
that's true but it's not because I'm
trying to select things to make it them
look bad it just was like that and
there's no other way to really say that
and that's basically the end of the day
all right up next the prosecution has
Zack Prince on the stand CEO of blockfi
basically the point of this was to share
the fact that you know FTX or Alam were
sending these fake balance sheets around
blockfi would ultimately go bankrupt
because they gave a bunch of loans to
Alam um but I think what's worth
highlighting here is how convoluted some
of these loans were because it's worth
understanding the only problem is I
barely understand it so in order to
explain it I just actually had someone
else do it Karly Riley has been covering
the trial as well through her Channel
overpriced jpegs and she's here to
explain sort of how convoluted things
were let me see if I can get this in one
shot okay FTX us gives a $400 million
line of credit to blockfi who then
starts lending $800 million to
Alam who in exchange for that $800
million posts collateral back to blockfi
who hold it in an account that they have
on FTX who lends basically all customer
deposits including block flies
collateral deposits to Alam who then
uses that money they borrowed from FTX
to partially pay back lenders including
blockfi who they paid back $150 million
to in November of 2022 as everything was
imploding but they never finished paying
them back because they went bankrupt all
right big thanks to Carly for that to be
honest even still afterwards I I don't
fully understand exactly how the blockfi
thing worked but um usually when things
are unnecessarily complicated it's
because someone's trying to hide a ball
somewhere so just understand that the
reason a lot of these loans were
structured in such a convoluted way was
ultimately so that Alam or FTX could
benefit and that's ultimately what
happened they ended up basically
siphoning money out of
[Music]
blockfi all right today we have another
big witness nishad Singh he's basically
the head of engineering at FTX but the
reason he's important is because he
describes finding out that Alam had
basically taken customer money and
confronting Sam about it on this balcony
pictured here nashad says that he was
pacing Behind These baskets on the left
and Sam was reclined on one of the white
like Chase chairs behind that in fact
it's not too far from where we are now
basically nishad confronts Sam saying
hey Caroline's really freaked out about
the net asset value situation and so am
I according to nashad Sam then replied
I'm not sure what there is to worry
about net asset value is fantastic by
almost any measure nashad replied what
about what Caroline said today and Gary
said today that there's 13 billion
borrowed and we can't pay it all Sam
said right that we are a little short on
deliverables he then says this has been
taxing me some 5 to 10% of my
productivity for this year now this um
is important because Sam and his
defenses excuse traditionally has been
hey I just found out about this debt
this giant debt that Alam had in late
2022 I mean look I wasn't running Alam I
didn't know exactly what was going on I
didn't know the size of their position
um uh a lot of these are things I've
learned over the last month that I
learned as I was sort of frantically
digging into this on you know November
6th November 7th November 8th but that
excuse now Falls flat because clearly we
have him saying that he knew about this
for over a year year after all he claims
it occupied 10% of his productivity so
that blows a large hole in the defense's
case that Sam was some innocent
bystander now today had a bunch of other
fun bits in it too like spreadsheets of
political donations spreadsheets of
venture capital Investments spreadsheets
of celebrity endorsements yes I like the
spreadsheets uh there's fun data in
there like the fact that celebrity
endorsements cost
$1.13
billion um in general just the feeling
was that hey alam's burning cash even as
their company is drowning in debt and
nobody seems to
care all right now we're on to the Cross
examination of nishad and for the first
time this is where the defense starts to
get their feet a little bit and things
flipped pretty quick the consensus the
day before was that all of that was
terrible for Sam NAD was a star witness
he was there confronting Sam on the
balcony he has this detailed story about
you know how he did it but when pressed
for details this is where things got
really weak the defense brought up his
lack of certainty earlier in his
conversations quote you told the
prosecutors that you had a surprising
amount of haziness when trying to recall
events in June and July of 2022 NAD
responds I don't remember saying those
exact words there was a lot I didn't
remember the details around from that
time wait which is it his testimony is
based around him remembering exactly
what he said to Sam B mfried now he's
saying he's hazy on the details but it
gets worse nashad said that when he
found out Alam had stolen money he felt
really betrayed and described it as evil
but then the defense pointed out that
nishad himself had borrowed money 3.7
million to buy a house for himself and
where did he get that money well he also
took it from FTX it turns out which just
destroys his credibility because how can
you think something's e evil and then
use it to get a big house for 3.7
million so nashad may have been the best
Storyteller for the prosecution but he
was also the easiest to pick apart for
the
defense all right day 11 we get Peter
Easton an accounting professor at Notre
Dame his job is to trace what happened
to the money at FTX he begins by showing
a chart of the money Alam owed FTX 11.3
billion was the peak of their debts so
in theory Alam should have had that
money they owed as a balance in the bank
but instead the green line shows alam's
actual balance in Fiat they owed
billions of dollars that they didn't
have next Peter Easton showed how this
happened through co-mingling of funds
these are the different bank accounts
that Alam FTX their different entities
owned theoretically these all should be
separate which is why they're in their
own boxes but in reality the
transactions looked like this they were
all sending money to each other this is
why Alam didn't have the money they
spent it through these different shell
companies Peter Easton broke down
exactly how in four categories
investments in businesses political
contributions Charities and purchase of
properties then he showed exactly what
this looked like with charts like this
showing from left to right how customers
funds were sent to alamy to research and
then spent on some investment Sam
himself wanted they even had chat LW of
Sam directing these Investments Peter
showed multiple examples like this Alam
stealing customers money we saw it over
and over and over and over the effect of
all this was the feeling that almost all
of spf's donations Venture Capital
charity politic contributions it was all
paid for by his customers which led us
finally to this a pie chart showing what
Alam owed customers along with a
breakout of what they actually spent it
on on and lo and behold only a small
fraction 2.3 billion was held aside for
actual customers everything else was
spent on things like this and seeing
this chart was devastating for Sam
because it simplified an incredibly
complicated topic it's a basically one
easily readable chart now we're going to
come back to Peter Easton because he's
really interesting but first I need to
talk about what happened the next
day so up on the stand we have K sun on
day 12th FTX is General Council he's
being asked about what happened during
the collapse of FTX when they're looking
to raise money to save the company now
at some point they turned to a company
called Apollo which only is important
because Apollo finds out FTX is $7
billion short on customer funds and they
ask Sam for a legal justification as to
why the funds were missing at Alama and
he asked me K son to come up with a
legal justification the prosecution then
asks and did you come to any conclusions
answer yes that there were no legal
justifications for the money being taken
away Kon eventually admits though quote
I did tell him that there were
theoretical arguments but none of them
was supported by the facts and one of
those theoretical arguments became the
famous margin lending defense basically
in fx's terms of service there were two
types of customers regular customers and
margin trading customers regular C
customers couldn't have their assets
lent out margin trading customers had a
separate to where they agreed that they
could have their funds lent out and the
theoretical argument is that whenever
Alam borrowed money they weren't
borrowing from regular customers they
were borrowing from these margin lending
customers which they were allowed to do
the only issue with this is that Canon
said that he quote previewed this
argument with NAD and ramik and they had
pulled some numbers that showed that it
was not supported by the facts question
did you Rel L that to the defendant
answer yes how did he acknowledge it he
said yep
yep okay we know this is true because of
Peter Easton's testimony earlier who
showed some of these numbers on this
graph in red you have how much Alam owed
customers and in green you have how much
Alam was borrowing in the spot margin
program as you can see there are
billions of dollars still missing that
couldn't be explained by this argument
despite this Sam would still try to use
it later in interviews with people like
George Stephanopoulos my understanding
is a few things happen the first is
there is a margin trading facility on
FTX by which users can lend out funds by
which other users borrow funds and so
there are explicit cases where there is
you know marging extended where there is
borrow lending if Alam is borrowing the
money that belongs to FDX
depositors that's a bright red line
isn't it there are a lot of cases where
that's actually explicitly part of the
programs and that are happening not here
here it says that the digital assets may
not be loaned to FTX trading as you can
see there Sam is just sort of trying out
this argument see if anyone bites uh but
even at the time I knew that this
couldn't be true because we had evidence
that it wasn't and I confronted Sam
about it but I talked to somebody from
Alama and asked how big the position of
like or how many people had assets in
the type of accounts that that terms of
service would apply to versus the
regular terms of service which said you
couldn't use their money and they said
it was about a billion that was in the
margin trading or the the margin like U
side of things where you could reuse
their funds or whatever and there was
the rest of it was not there so does
that mean the rest of the money was
stolen I mean like it seems like you're
putting all your eggs behind this one
excuse about you know there was this
separate side of the terms of service
how do you address everyone
else so I don't have all the day in
front of me my memory is that it was
substantially more than a billion um in
the margin trading program um but I
don't have that day in front of me right
now so I can't verify that well now we
do have the real numbers and of course
as K's son his lawyer told Sam at the
time the argument makes no sense because
the numbers just don't support what he's
saying and we were
right day 13 uh this basically marks the
end of the prosecution's case and the
beginning of the defenses now originally
we said they didn't really have many
people who were going to testify besides
Sam bman freed eventually the defense
did find one guy and that is Joseph
pimbley A Financial Consultant who takes
the stand next now his job is basically
to undo the work of Peter Easton and
provide an alternative Financial case to
do this he claimed that 78% of accounts
on FTX had spot margin lending in
enabled trying to give credit to this
margin lending explanation or to put it
another way only $2 billion that were
borrowed wouldn't be allowed to be
honest this was pretty confusing because
this basically flips Peter Easton's
testimony on its head you have these two
Financial experts basically both saying
opposite things uh so to draw a
distinction between these two witnesses
the prosecution in Cross asked Mr
pimbley if he had only looked at the FTX
database says yes that is correct
question you can't draw further
conclusions beyond that correct they
point out question you didn't look at
the Fiat at account in FTX did you and
you did not engage in any Financial
tracing correct pimbley answers of
course not no no sir the idea here being
to distinguish Peter Easton as the
person who actually traced crypto and
Fiat whereas pimbley just looked at a
single database that FTX maintained and
could have tainted even though I guess
they had a point here I I I do think
this was a net win for the defense
because the goal and I think what they
achieved was muddying the waters by
presenting their own set of numbers that
was very different and look speaking of
alternative stories this is where things
got really interesting because the
defense next calls up their star witness
I guess Sam bankman freed to the
stand all right let me start this by
saying it is very risky when a defendant
testifies because it can open you up to
cross-examination but at this point I
think everyone agreed that Sam doesn't
really have much to lose and he loves to
talk and so Sam's explanation for what
happened the last few years began and
you won't be surprised to find out that
it's very different from the prosecution
story now some of it consisted of
innocent explanations things like how
Sam autod deleted messages on Signal
that a prosecution kind of implied he
was hiding evidence Sam claims this was
just a precaution he learned called the
New York Times test where you want to
avoid writing things down because a lot
of innocuous things can look pretty bad
out of context other times Sam wouldn't
just say it was innocent he would claim
ignorance of what was happening he would
say things like I wasn't entirely sure
what was happening and I wish I had a
better understanding than I did and
there were teams that were managing this
process Sam even says he didn't even
know about the $8 billion hole in his
company called the Fiat ad account quot
did you know what Fiat at was at the
time no did you later learn yes Sam says
he didn't even have conversations about
it until October of 2022 which if you
remember directly contradicts what we
heard from other employees he even
claims he was very surprised when he
found out they owed a billion dollar
basically his version of events has him
the surprised CEO you know at the Helm
of the Titanic who only finds out it's
all sinking when it's too late to say
and all of the illegal actions taken by
his you know company were really because
of Caroline Ellison NAD and Gary and all
of it was without his knowledge and look
look it's I guess it's a story it's a
nice story but is it going to hold up to
cross let's find
[Music]
out okay Sam is up on the stand Miss
Sassoon is the lawyer for
cross-examination he's basically evasive
she's ruthless uh so here's what
happened next Miss Sassoon asks were you
not involved at all anomy to trading in
2022 Sam says I was not involved as a
general principal in day-to-day trading
then miss Sasson showed him being
involved in day-to-day trading oxy and
maps with text messages to Caroline
saying quote $1 to $2 million of each
over the next day or two question did
you see that yep and so began the
ruthless destruction of Sam's
credibility he would say he didn't do
something uh and and then basically we'd
get hard evidence that he did we also
got a really annoying strategy from Sam
where he just would try to dodge every
question about things he said in the
past like do you recall that Sam would
say not specifically but I'm not saying
that I didn't or Miss Sassoon would ask
yes or no you stated on this podcast you
were not involved at all in Alam to
trading Sam I don't recall what I said
and then we would just hear this I
wasn't super involved in Alam I was not
involved at all in the trading um been
for years things continue like this with
Sam saying things like I'm not sure I
don't remember quote I don't remember
what I said in Miss as soon each time
would show him exactly what he said he
doesn't remember and Sam basically
refused to say yes even to things that
were obviously true like a question did
you or did you not Market FTX
internationally safe yes he did that
like a million times he'd say I don't
specifically remember that I'm not sure
which I'm not sure the benefit of saying
you don't remember this but there are
definitely negatives to it which was
pissing off the judge and the jury after
all Sam's whole case rests on his
version of events which is very
different from everyone else's but when
pressed on basic statements he made if
he suddenly gets amnesia and can't
recall why should anyone believe it when
he does recall things this felt like a
really big trap had been set for Sam and
he kind of just walked right into it
not that things went better for him when
he did answer though because at some
point Miss Sassoon asked about
regulation and he did answer that
question you wanted your followers to
think that consumer protection was
important to you right answer sure but
this was really just for PR wasn't it
answer no she then pulls up a message
Sam himself wrote and had him read it
out to the jury saying yeah just PR
regulators and
look that's a lot just on paper that's
already so damning but having Sam
himself actually repeat it back to the
judge and jury just encapsulates this
story so well because from the beginning
Sam believed he can talk his way out of
this only to have himself eviscerated
not necessarily by other people but by
his own words most of all there's just
something so poetic about that and look
cross- examination went on for a while
but I think that was the most powerful
moment for me personally and it
concludes the major Revelations from his
testimony so now after hearing all the
evidence I think it's time for a jury
[Music]
decision all right we have a a verdict
it's only been 3 hours since the jury
started deliberating which usually means
it was a fast decision so if you want to
put in your thoughts at home I have the
verdict right here um all seven counts
guilty baby so this is a pretty happy
ending obviously for me but we won't
know the sentencing um until until March
in fact I think it's a happy ending for
a lot of the customers at least some
cold comfort that there looks like
there's going to be some justice done
here and for this case for now it's over
either way hope you enjoyed this
detailed look at the FTX trial thanks
for
watching okay before you go I just
wanted to say I'm going to be releasing
some tasteful photos for my bathtub
shoot on patreon as wallpapers coffee
hasn't paid his tab in weeks and I'm
broke what are you Whispering about over
there oh nothing I'm just telling
everybody they can get early access to
these amazing videos on patreon by
supporting us hey that's actually pretty
nice thanks
Maxwell you know and to think I was mad
at you earlier All Is Forgiven that's
good you know last thing I found this
camera of yours and there's some pretty
insane photos you took we're deleting
these right we can't show the public
this oh those of course you know you've
been working so hard let me take care of
that for you you get going now well
thanks yeah sure just uh take care of it
and I think I'm done with the $40
million pinhouse see you back at the
[Music]
bar